off to Madrid Spain now where a
motorcyclist is attempting to ride
across a 130 foot puddle so at first
glance it just looks like a giant puddle
that's like this deep but this is no
ordinary puddle it's a monster five foot
deep puddle there's a camera guy
standing in the puddle like filming and
he's like easily waist-deep
I never thought this would be possible
to see a motorcycle glide across water
sensation we travel to Spain to talk
with Yvonne about gliding on water where
Mandela came mas rapido me vo fue la
primera porque no sabes que rezian
betina's la moto que erection bar dinner
vas a tener to
not so easy
Itsuki bomb three hours and three
failures before finally crossing the
mudbath
so how did Yvonne do the seemingly
impossible to skim across the surface of
this lake
you need a counterbalancing force to
counteract the weight of gravity pushing
the bike down and that force is provided
by something called hydroplaning or
aquaplaning you slap water hard enough
it will sting because the molecules
can't get all the way quick enough for a
brief instant it's as if they're solid
and that's what he's doing here he's
hitting the water fast enough hard
enough with the motorbike that
momentarily it's as if he's on a solid
surface the key to making this trick
work is to have a good entry speed is
once he hits that water he's not gaining
any additional traction so he starts
aquaplaning and then as his speed
decreases he still his aquaplaning did
he just reaches the other side and then
he's got traction on dryland and a
maximum of 40 so how fast does Yvonne
have to go in order to hydroplane to the
other side
Parrinello wasi atun calculative
tomorrow who knows send a certain Tommy
Laura physics class would be a lot more
interesting if my physics teacher got on
a bike and explain me hydroplaning this
way